SPEAKER: I'm really
excited to introduce
our speaker for today.
His name is Antonio Neves,
who is a nationally recognized
leadership speaker,
author, and workplace
consultant to top
organizations and startups.
I actually first
heard of Antonio
from our Global Head of
Diversity staffing, Daisy.
And she actually handed me
his book, which some of you
got today-- "50 Ways to Excel
in Your First Job and in Life."
I can honestly say I
read it front to back
and agreed with
Daisy that it was
crucial to get Antonio in
here today to speak to you all
and share his nuggets of wisdom.
Just to tell you a bit
more about Antonio,
he has delivered
hundreds of keynotes
at corporations, conferences,
trade shows, and universities,
including Starwood Hotels and
Resorts, Stanford University,
for all of the Stanford folks
here, the American Society
of Health System Pharmacists,
the Consumer Electronics
Show, and many more.
An award-winning journalist,
for over 10 years,
Antonio worked in the
television industry
in New York City as a
reporter and a correspondent
with top television networks,
including NBC, PBS, and BET
networks.
A Google search
will also tell you
that Antonio began his
television career co-hosting
shows on Children's Television
Network, Nickelodeon.
Antonio's business
writing can be read
on inc.com entrepreneur.com.
And he's the author
of three books,
including "50 Ways to Excel in
Your First Job and in Life."
A graduate of Western
Michigan University,
and earned a Master's
of Science degree
from Columbia University.
Please provide a warm
welcome to Antonio Neves.
[APPLAUSE]
If I have the opportunity,
I have the pleasure
of traveling anywhere between
15,000 to 20,000 miles a month,
speaking at trade
associations, at corporations,
at universities, you name it.
And I got really
excited when I saw
that Google in Mountain
View is on the calendar
because as I mentioned
earlier, Napa Valley is not
too far from here.
So I remember looking at my
wife home and I was talking.
I was like, you
know, honey, I've
been working
really, really hard.
I've been traveling a lot.
And I think what
I'm going to do,
after I finish up at Google,
is go to wine country
for a few days by myself.
I'm going to go taste some wine
and walk through the vineyards
and relax and get a little
bit of R&R for Antonio.
And my wife, she looked at me.
And she smiled, gave
this weird look.
And she said, oh, is that so?
And then she reminded me
that just a couple of months
ago, she gave birth to
our twins, our daughter
Harper and our son August.
So needless to say, after
I've finished today,
I'll be going directly
to the airport.
I won't be going to taste
any wine whatsoever.
Again, it's an honor
to join you here
to talk about my book, "50
Ways to Excel in Your First Job
and in Life."
This is critical to me
because my passion really
is supporting
young professionals
in doing exceptional
things in their career,
making them aware of the
choices that they have in life.
And the reason why I wrote this
book is because frankly, what I
share in this book
are things that
have made a big
difference in my life.
And I would not be here
talking to you today
without some of those key
lessons I share in that book.
You see, as I traveled
across the country, those 15,
those 20,000 miles
a month, what I
see are a lot of
young professionals
and college students
who, on paper, on paper,
everything looks right.
But as we all know, on paper
only tells part of the story.
Maybe you go to the
right university.
Maybe you have the right
grade point average.
Maybe you're part of
the right organizations.
Maybe you've had the
right internships.
But what I've seen
firsthand are so
many young professionals
who are kind of
like a high-powered jet.
They're barreling down
the runway at full speed.
But for some reason,
they can't take off.
They're struggling to
take off in their career.
And the research
actually backs this up.
We can look at some
research from Gallup
way back in 2015,
last year, that
said employers are finding that
many college graduates are not
prepared with the
skills that they need
to succeed in the workforce.
Now, the skills they're
talking about something
called soft skills.
That's about leadership.
That's communication.
That's collaboration,
emotional intelligence.
They say young professionals
like yourself aren't prepared
with creative thinking.
And they say young
professionals like yourself
aren't ready with good
problem-solving skills.
Now, on the flipside,
Deloitte did a study.
And that said that young
professionals and college
students like
yourselves don't think
that their skill sets,
their academic education,
is valued by employers.
So obviously, we have a divide.
And the stakes are
extremely high, right?
Because a corporation, when
they hire you to work with them,
they spend a lot of money
to find you, to develop you,
to groom you to succeed.
And all of you who are getting
your education right now,
you've spent a lot of
money on your education,
getting ready to
succeed in your life.
So you want a return
on that investment.
So what I hope to
share in this book
is what can bridge that divide.
You know, before
I go any further,
I think it's really important
to share a little bit more
about my background so you can
tell where I'm coming from,
where I share this information.
So if you happen to do
a Google search on me,
you'll find that I worked in the
television industry in New York
City for over 10 years as a
reporter, as a correspondent,
as a host with NBC.
I've interviewed top CEOs,
executives, and entrepreneurs,
the men and the
women that you see
on the covers of "Fast
Company" and "Inc. Magazine."
With PBS, on "The NewsHour"
and the [INAUDIBLE] news,
I've covered serious topics
like international trade,
the economy, education,
the Supreme Court.
With "E!
News Live," I've interviewed
popstars like Aaron Carter.
With the BET networks, I've
created documentary series.
My writing can be read
in a variety of outlets
like "Inc. Magazine"
and entrepreneur.com.
I lead the higher education
team at International Personal
Branding Platform about me.
And a little-known fact
that was mentioned briefly
in my introduction is that
I began my career co-hosting
shows on a television network
called Nickelodeon, way
back in 2002 to 2004 or 2005.
If you're confused, I'm
the handsome brother
in the corner with
the dreadlocks.
This was a long time ago
when I began my career.
So if you've ever
asked yourself,
you know, I wonder whatever
happens to former Nickelodeon
hosts.
What's up?
How's everybody doing today?
Good to see you.
Now, look, I don't
show these credentials,
I don't show these
networks to you
and all this fun stuff to
brag or to boast, by no means.
Because these are my credits,
my Google search today.
But 15 years ago, if you
did that exact same search,
this is what you would find.
You wouldn't find anything.
Maybe for many of
you, this is where
you are right now
as you are beginning
your career, this blank
slate, this blank canvas.
You see, I'm from a
small town in Michigan.
I'm from one of
those small towns
where people do not leave.
I am from a family
that experienced
a lot of instability.
Before I graduated from high
school, I moved over 15 times,
over 15 times in
my small hometown.
Between my mother and father are
a total of like six divorces.
I also know what
it's like firsthand
to live in a
shelter for battered
and abused women and children.
I'm a first generation
college student,
the first person my
family to go to college
and be able to earn a degree.
Now, I don't share
any of this with you
to elicit any
sympathy, by no means.
I only know if I had to share
with you, for many years
I was ashamed of it, and
I was embarrassed by it.
But oddly enough, I found
that those things right there
are many of the reasons why I'm
standing here with you today.
It built up a certain amount
of grit that a lot of people
are talking about today.
There's a great book out
right now called "Grit"
by Angela Duckworth.
Let's build up that grit, that
perseverance, that resilience,
that character to move forward
through challenging times.
Now, many of you, there's
something about you
that's unique that someone would
never find in a Google search.
And I want you to
know that whatever
that is that people
may not know right now,
use that to your advantage,
not your disadvantage.
Own that, as opposed
to hide that.
And you have a blank
canvas right now.
As you begin this summer
and you begin your career,
you have a blank
canvas, if you will,
to paint and to create
and to scope what
you most want in your life.
And I believe the
three things that we'll
get into today that will allow
you to do that are these three
topics right here, that is being
willing to turn up the volume,
being willing to find the
edge, and being willing to do
something that seems obvious.
But for some reason, not a lot
of people do that, that is,
find people who make you better.
And if there's a
thesis of everything
that I do of my work,
it's this right here.
That is, being willing to
be the CEO of your career.
I've had the opportunity over
my life to interview and profile
extremely talented
CEOs, entrepreneurs,
you name it, who've built
billion-dollar companies.
And one thing I've noticed in
these men and women is this,
is that they take
full accountability
and responsibility
for their experience.
They're willing
to have an agenda.
They're willing to have goals.
They're willing to be
proactive versus reactive.
A lot of employees come and
they wait for things to happen.
I'm inviting all of you over
the course of this summer
to be proactive and
make things happen.
Yes, Google's going to do
amazing things for you.
The question begs, what
can you do for yourself
during this time
that you are here?
So let's get into this
with turning up the volume.
Many years ago, I
started my career.
I worked briefly as a local
news reporter for a really small
television station.
Now, I remember walking into
my news station one day.
And my news director
happened to be sitting there.
And he was looking at a
reels that reporters had sent
in from all across the country.
These are men and
women that wanted
to work for the television
station that I worked for.
They wanted to replace me.
So he saw me.
And he called me into the office
to watch these reels with him.
And after a few moments of
watching some of the reels
with him, I had to
ask him to stop.
And we pushed pause.
Because what I noticed, as
we were watching these reels,
was that the volume was
turned down on the television.
Now, as we all know,
television it's an audio,
it's a visual medium.
So I said, boss, how can
you hire this young man
or hire this young
woman if you can't
hear what they are saying.
He looked at me.
He smiled.
It was as if he had been
anticipating this question.
And he said, Antonio,
I want to see if I
want to turn the volume up.
I want to see if I want
to turn the volume up.
Think about those moments
in life you've been at home
and five million different
things are going on.
The radio is blasting.
You're on social media.
You're cooking.
You're doing dishes.
You're having a conversation.
But something happens
to be happening
on the television that
grabs your attention
and you have to find that remote
control to turn up the volume
to see what's being said.
Or maybe you've been at
a party or a gathering.
And you're having a conversation
with her right here.
And she's cool, right?
Right?
We're having a
good conversation.
OK.
But at some point during
that party, that gathering,
you notice another conversation
happening over here
that you want to turn
the volume up on.
Like, hey, I'll see you later.
Deuces.
Well, believe it or
not, every single day
over the course of your
life-- and they say,
don't judge a book by its cover.
But let's be real.
Keep it 100, as they say.
People do.
People are determining
whether or not
they want to turn
the volume up on you
or press mute in your career.
They are doing that based
on what time you show up.
on how you present yourself.
They are doing that based on
your body language and energy.
They are determining
whether or not
they want to turn the
volume up on you based
on what shows up with you
when you come into a room.
Have you ever been
to a gathering
or a party and the door opens
and you look over and it's Tim?
And you're like oh, Tim.
And you know the party
is about to get worse?
You know that person that makes
the party-- you're like, oh.
And there have been other times,
you're at this same party.
You hear the door open.
You look.
And it's Deborah.
And you're like,
oh, Deborah's here.
And you know the party's
about to get better.
Do people want to turn
the volume up on you
or turn it down and press mute?
In this day and age, we hear
a lot about personal brand
and how important it is for you
to develop your personal brand.
Well, the best
definition that I've
heard that relates to
personal branding is this.
Your personal brand is
what people say about you
when you are not around.
That's a simple way to put it.
I don't care if it's
online or in person.
Your personal brand is
what people say about you
when you are not around.
What I invite all of you to
do after you leave here today
is open up a Google
Chrome browser,
and then open up
a private window,
and then Google your name and
see what those results are.
Because guess what?
You're not around when
somebody does that.
You meet someone.
What do you do?
You Google their name.
It's so funny when I do
this exercise with people.
They'll go to that
private browser.
Don't go to a regular
browser because you Google
yourself all the time anyways.
But go to the private browser.
Google your name.
And I see people do things
like, that's not me.
Other people look
at that and say,
that's not a
flattering photo of me.
People look at
that and say, yeah,
that last Instagram post isn't
really what I'm all about.
But it is me.
Your personal brand is
what people say about you
when you're not around.
Now, to continue on this theme
of turning up the volume,
do we have any country
music fans in the room?
Raise your hand.
Six people.
OK, well, we'll talk
about hip-hop instead.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm a big hip-hop fan.
And way back in 2001, I went to
a rap concert in New York City,
in Irving Plaza.
I went to go see one
of my favorite artists
at the time, this guy by
the name of Talib Kweli.
And he is still one of
my favorite artists.
I remember getting
to the venue early,
right when the doors opened.
And as I was walking
in, I heard someone
say from the loudspeakers,
ladies and gentlemen,
it's time for our opening act.
You don't know who
this person is.
You probably haven't
heard the music.
But they're extremely talented.
Please give your love,
please give your attention,
please give your energy
to our opening act.
And this opening act came
out and started performing.
Now, I invite all of you
to think about those times
that you've been to a concert
and the opening act comes out
and you are not
familiar with them,
and you are not familiar
with their music.
What do you do?
Well, people I know, typically,
they'll pull out their phone.
They'll have a conversation.
They'll grab some beverages.
They'll do anything
but pay attention
to the person on stage.
It's not because
they're not talented.
they're not gifted.
It's just that they
don't have any context.
And look, in 2001,
there was no SoundCloud.
So you weren't researching
this in advance.
But interestingly enough,
after that opening act started
performing, they made me and
a few others in that venue
want to turn the volume up.
And the reason why they made
me want to turn the volume up
is because, even though pretty
much no one-- and I mean
no one-- was paying
attention to them,
they still were giving
absolutely everything.
It was as if this
opening act was
performing to a sold-out
arena, while no one was
paying attention.
It was as if the
pope this opening act
was a multi-platinum Grammy
Award winning artist.
It was as if this opening
act was already performing
at the MTV Music Awards.
While no one was
paying attention,
they were giving
absolutely everything.
The question I have for
everyone in this room
is, what do you do when no
one is paying attention?
Think about those times
you've been in the classroom
or you've been involved
in a group project,
and you know there is that one
person, because there's always
that one person that will do
all the work in that group.
You know that person?
Do you let them do all the
work just because they will?
Or maybe you've been
really committed to getting
in better shape when you meet a
friend of yours a couple times
a week at 6:00 AM
to go to the gym.
But the night before, you
get a text message that says,
dude, not going to
be able to make it.
Do you still go to the gym
even though that person is not
going to be there?
Or maybe even really cognizant
of focusing on your health
and wellness and not
eating processed foods,
but it's late night.
You're tired.
The last thing you want
to do when you get home
is cook something.
And you happen to pass by
a fast food restaurant.
Do you still pull in
when no one is watching?
What do you do when
no one pays attention?
I'm a firm believer
that what you
do when no one is
paying attention
will deliver the results
you do or do not want.
Well, getting back to that
concert way back in 2001,
that person on stage
really impressed me.
But time came and went.
But I remember in 2004,
three years later-- 2004,
three years later, I
remember hearing some buzz
about some new
artist on the scene.
Some new album was
dropped the everyone was
raving about and talking about.
So I keep all the ticket
stubs for the concerts
and the sporting
events that I go to.
And I went and grabbed
that ticket stub
and I cross-referenced
it with that album
and all those articles.
And I found out
that that person who
was giving absolutely everything
when no one was watching
three years earlier was someone
by the name of Kanye West.
Now, it goes without saying
that Kanye West believes
in Kanye West.
[LAUGHTER]
Is that fair to say?
The question is if
Kanye West did not
believe in Kanye West three
years earlier, who would have?
People give this man a lot of
ridicule and a lot of flack
for his social media
rants and if you
want to call them,
diatribes and his opinions.
But I don't look at
this man the same way
because for three years,
before anyone knew his name,
he was giving absolutely
everything while no one was
paying attention.
In many ways, I feel
like he's earned it.
He can say whatever
he wants to say.
His success didn't come three
months later, six months later,
one year later, two years later.
No, three years later,
the album came out.
While no one was
watching, he was
giving absolutely everything.
What do you do when
no one is watching?
What this gets across for
me this whole notion of,
you don't climb a
mountain by accident
over the course of your career.
I talk to a lot of
young professionals.
And I do a lot of consulting
with organizations.
And a similar refrain
is that people
want more responsibility.
They want the bigger projects.
They want the bigger
titles, you name it.
But you don't climb a
mountain by accident.
If somehow, I could
miraculously airlift you
to the top of Mount Kilimanjaro
or to the top of, let's say,
Mount Everest, which is
nearly 30,000 feet altitude,
what would happen
when you got out?
You would take in
this amazing view.
And you would probably
pass out afterwards.
And the reason why
is because your lungs
have not earned being
at that altitude.
You have not done the work
when no one is watching.
It's no wonder when we think
about reality television--
I enjoy the reality television
competitions like anyone else.
But there's no wonder that
one or two years after someone
wins that television
competition,
we no longer hear that
man or woman's name.
It's not because, again,
they're not talented
or they're not gifted.
It's because they
haven't done the work
when no one was watching.
It was handed to
them prematurely.
Has anyone in this room ever--
has anybody here ever driven
a stick-shift before?
OK, what happens
if you try to start
a stick-shift in fifth gear?
You're going to stall.
Yeah, you're not going
to have a lot of luck.
What I see happening with
people in their careers
is they're trying to get
to fifth gear right away.
The opportunity
that all of us have
is to be willing to earn first
gear, to earn second gear,
to earn third year, and
even learn to enjoy those
stalls because that right there
is where the magic happens.
What I want to get across
to you is this right here,
that ideas are useless.
Ideas are useless until you
breathe some type of life
into them.
Right now, on some
of your hard drives
are some of the best ideas
ever that you have never
taken action on.
Right now, somewhere in
one of your notebooks
that's packed away
in a file cabinet,
or maybe in your notebook right
in front of you right now,
are amazing ideas
that for some reason,
you have yet to take action on.
Right now, some
of the best ideas
are happening over brunch
conversations with mimosas.
But after that second
mimosa, the idea
goes out of the window.
Ideas are useless unless
you breathe life into them.
When I started off
in Nickelodeon,
I didn't start off
as a television host.
I actually started off working
on a show as a production
assistant.
Now, if you know anything
about working in television
and working as a
production assistant,
you know that it is not a sexy--
it is not a glamorous job.
You're making coffee.
You're making photocopies.
You're holding cue cards.
You're carrying
equipment around.
But one of my goals
was to be a writer.
So after all my responsibilities
were complete, I would write.
I took writing classes.
I studied great writers.
And slowly but surely,
my writing improved.
And after a while, I
built up enough confidence
to go to the head writer
of the television show
that I worked on to ask him
if he'd be willing to give me
feedback on my scripts.
And he said absolutely.
And I learned
another key lesson.
That is nine times out of 10,
people are willing to help you.
But it is your responsibility
to ask for that help.
Over the course of
the summer, there
are amazing people
on this Google campus
and throughout the organization.
They are willing to help you.
But again, you have
them take accountability
and responsibility
and be willing to ask
for that support, to
ask for that 15 minutes,
ask for that guidance.
So after a while, I
started giving my scripts
to the head writer on the show.
And slowly but surely, they
got a little bit better.
Then they got worse.
And then they got better.
But I'll never forget, one day
the head writer came up to me
in my cubicle.
And he said, Antonio, one of
our writers is out sick today.
Do you happen to have
any scripts ready to go?
I had a lot of
scripts ready to go.
I handed it to him.
That day, one of
my scripts appeared
on the television show.
A few weeks later, I began
regularly contributing
to that television show.
And I eventually
became a staff writer.
And I learned a great lesson.
That is, all it takes is
someone being out sick
one day for your opportunity
to present itself.
The question begs,
will you be ready
when that opportunity comes?
Because I've seen
that opportunity come.
Someone is out sick.
Someone goes on vacation.
Someone leaves to go to another
company and that slot opens up
and people step into it.
But unfortunately, because they
haven't done the requisite work
when no one is watching, they
struggle in that situation.
If you're an NFL football
fan, a lot of people
talk about quarterback Tom Brady
who's won multiple Super Bowls.
What a lot of people don't
know is that that starting job
was not Tom Brady's initially.
Tom Brady was a sixth
round draft pick.
But there was
another quarterback
by the name of Drew Bledsoe who
got injured in a football game.
Tom Brady came in for him.
And the rest is history.
And the reason why he was
able to excel and succeed
is because he did the work
when no one is watching.
And what I hear a lot when
I talk about doing the work,
I hear a lot of things.
You know, I'm just
going to wing it.
I'm just going to wing it.
I'm good on my feet.
Don't wing it.
I can tell you this right
here is that winging is easy
when you're well prepared.
It's easy to go off script
when you know the script.
It's easy to break the rules
when you know the rules.
It's easy to get off
of an exit on a highway
when you know how to get
back on and know eventually
where you're going.
Be willing to do the work
when no one is watching.
And after you've been
willing to do that,
I invite you to
regularly find the edge
over the course of your
life and in your career.
Do we have any former athletes
in this room, current athletes,
former athletes?
I don't care if you
did this in high school
or you do this in a
rec leagues intramural.
But you know those moments
before the whistle goes off
or the gun goes off in that
football game, that baseball
game, that track race,
volleyball, lacrosse,
you name it, and
all of a sudden you
get that increased heart rate
and you get those butterflies?
That right there tells you
that you are finding the edge.
And do we have any
performers in the room?
Maybe you act.
Maybe you dance.
Maybe you debate.
Maybe you give public talks
like this one right here.
But in some capacity--
you do open mic night--
but you have to get
in front of people.
And you know before they
call your name as your cue
to come on, and all of
a sudden your throat
gets really constricted and
your hands start trembling?
That right there tells you
that you are finding the edge.
And has anyone in this room ever
had a crush on someone before?
A lot of laughter.
One hand went up though.
OK, two hands.
Thank you, sir.
I have a copy of my
book for you afterwards.
But you know when
you've been crushing
on someone all semester?
And all of a sudden
this person you've
been crushing on all
semester shows up,
and she just happens
to be in the third row?
She has glasses on, a t-shirt.
Her hair is pulled back.
She's starting to
blush now because she
realizing that the guy on
stage is talking about her.
You're crushing on her.
You gotta make a
decision that one day
when she shows up in front of
you, what are you going to do?
I've been crushing
on her all semester?
You check your breath.
You say, what's up, girl?
Forgive me.
Thank you for playing along.
But that feeling right
there is finding the edge.
I invite all of you to
think about the last week
of your life.
Think about yesterday.
And I'm a firm believer
if you have not
felt that, you are not
growing and you are not
moving forward in your life.
As someone told me
a long time ago,
if you are not close
enough to the edge,
then you are taking
up too much space.
I believe that
with my everything.
If you are not close
enough to the edge,
then you are taking
up too much space.
What we're really talking
about is the unique combination
of fear and excitement.
Many psychologists will tell you
that fear and excitement pretty
much are the exact same emotion.
Fritz Perls, the father
of Gestalt Therapy, once
said that "Fear is excitement
without the breath."
"Fear is excitement
Think about professional sports,
if they say someone chokes,
right?
And it's the end
of the game they
miss that easy
lay-up or they double
fault in the tennis match.
Typically, they say
that person was tight.
They choked.
If you're tight
and you're choking,
that means you're not breathing.
You're operating
from a place of fear.
But when you think
about when things
are going great in someone's
life, specifically athletes
or that talk just
goes extremely well,
they say you are in the
zone or you are in flow.
You are breathing.
The beautiful thing
is that we all
have that opportunity to choose
between fear and excitement.
I can think back to
a time in my life
when I had to do exactly that.
This is way back
in 2002 or 2003.
This is in Times
Square, 1515 Broadway.
This is the building where
people, thousands of people,
came all across the country,
all across the world,
to look up into
these glass walls
into a studio to watch tapings
of MTV's "Total Request Live."
Well, just a few floors
up is where we recorded
Nickelodeon's "U-Pick Live."
And I remember one day
that the main host was out.
And me and someone else were
given the main hosting duties.
Now, I'm in the studio.
And there's an x on the
floor where I stand.
And in front of me are
these three cameras
with these big, bright
lights on me like this.
Behind the cameras
are people walking,
getting ready for the show.
There are kids and
their parents who
had traveled from all
across the country
to join us for this taping.
And I hear the director
say from the control
room on a loudspeaker, we're
going live in 30 seconds.
In 30 seconds we're going live.
I remember sitting there
saying, wow, in 30 seconds,
we're going to be
broadcasting live
to millions of people
all across the country,
and as a bonus, Canada.
[LAUGHTER]
Canada really tripped me
out because I was like,
what happens in Canada?
I had no idea.
So I'm sitting there like, wow,
millions of people, my family,
my friends are watching,
millions of people
all across the country.
Canada, the kid has come so far.
Wow, Canada.
[LAUGHTER]
And then slowly but
surely, I was like, wow,
millions of people.
That's a lot of people.
I was like, one,
two-- I realized
I wouldn't be able to
count to a million in time.
I was like, Canada, that's
this unknown factor.
[LAUGHTER]
And all of a sudden,
I shifted from being
really excited to like,
yo, millions of people,
to millions of people.
that's a lot of people.
My mom is watching.
My grandma's watching.
And as I shifted, all of a
sudden, the stage manager said,
Antonio, we're going
live in 5, 4, 3, 2.
And he points at me.
And the red light
comes on the camera.
The red light means we
are now broadcasting live
to millions of people all across
the country, and as a bonus--
AUDIENCE: Canada.
ANTONIO NEVES: Right.
That right there is my moment to
welcome people to today's show
in the camera.
But instead of doing
that, I did this.
I--
[GRUNTS]
I froze.
I was a deer in headlights.
Some people would say I choked.
This was my moment, my
moment that I had dreamed of.
I'm on live TV.
And I froze.
And what's wild
about this moment was
all I could think about, all I
could think about was cheese.
All I could think
about was cheese.
Don't judge me.
And the reason why all I
could think about was cheese
was about three
years earlier when
I graduated from Western
Michigan University,
even though I had aspirations
of working in the entertainment
industry, I didn't do that.
I got afraid.
And I took a safe job as a sales
representative selling cheese.
Now, look, you heard
about my background.
I didn't have the
highest aspirations
for myself growing up.
But I can guarantee you, when
someone came up to me when
I was a kid and
they said, Antonio,
what you want to be
when you grow up,
I never said I wanted
to sell cheese.
I remember going
home for the holidays
when I had this
job selling cheese
and I would see
friends at the mall who
chose not to go to college,
and some are unemployed
and not doing so great.
And they're like, oh, Antonio
Neves, college graduate.
How are you?
What are you up to these days?
And I would say,
I'm selling cheese.
And they would say, I'm sorry.
Is everything OK?
Do you need some money?
I'm like, I have a job,
company car, benefits, 401(k).
I was selling cheese.
And I really despised this job.
And the wild thing about
selling cheese was this.
I was a beast at selling cheese.
My cheese game
was so ridiculous.
Seriously, you have no idea--
gruyere, cheddar, Jack,
manchego, mozzarella, brie.
Somebody give me one.
AUDIENCE: Gouda.
ANTONIO NEVES: Gouda, somebody
got fancy in the back.
My cheese game was ridiculous.
I was exceptional at this,
which really confused me
because I didn't like my job.
But I was good at it.
Another one of those
ding, ding, ding,
moments came up in my life.
And that was this.
Just because you're
good at something
doesn't mean that you're
supposed to be doing it.
I hope that many of you never
encounter this in your life.
But odds are, you maybe will.
Just because you're
good at something
doesn't mean you're
supposed to be doing it.
I speak to a lot of
university students.
And I'll ask questions like,
so what are you majoring in?
And I'll get an answer like, oh,
integrated supply management.
I'm like, cool, great.
How long have you been
into that subject?
They're like, I'm
not really into it.
So why are you majoring in this?
Some magazine said the
year that I graduate,
there'll be jobs available.
It's no wonder when you
look at the studies that
say that workplace engagement,
people who are actively engaged
in their jobs in the United
States, is less than 1/3
of the working population.
It's no wonder that
people leave jobs
on average in less
than 24 months.
Because we're choosing things
that we don't want to do.
Just because you're
good at something
doesn't mean you're
supposed to be doing it.
And I hung in there.
I sold cheese for almost a year.
But I felt this metaphorical
tap on my shoulder
that whole year saying,
this is a good job,
but it's not your job.
I felt guilty.
On Sunday nights, I would
get sick to my stomach
knowing I had to go
to work the next day.
So I decided to make
a decision, to lean
in to a little bit of
fear and excitement.
And I did the scariest
thing I ever did in my life.
And I moved to New York City
with $700 in my bank account.
$700.
I knew just one person.
This is pre-Facebook, Twitter,
LinkedIn, Snapchat, Yik
Yak, you name it.
That one person I knew
it was kind enough
to give me a floor to
sleep on, on three couch
cushions for a few months.
I slept on three couch
cushions on a floor, not
a couch, three couch cushions.
That's a big difference
when it comes to neck pain.
And when you have
$700 in New York City,
that doesn't go really far.
I have friends today that
pay $700 a month just
to park their car.
So I had to get to work.
And I remember working temp
jobs from 9:00 AM until 5:00 PM.
And then I would
work a retail job
at a store called H&M
from 6:00 PM until 10 PM.
And then when I
was lucky, I'd be
able to get a late
night catering job
serving food or serving
drinks from like 11:00 PM
to 2:00 AM or 3:00 AM.
Rinse, wash, repeat, do the
same thing the next day.
I was there with
meaning, with purpose.
I was there for a reason.
I was happy,
actually, doing this
because I knew I was
in the right place
to pursue my endeavors
to work as a storyteller
in the entertainment industry.
The crazy thing about this is
how many people in my circle
and in my life told me how
stupid I was for doing this.
Like, what are you doing?
Why would you give up a good job
with benefits, a 401(k) plan,
all these different
things, to do this,
to go into this uncertainty?
Maybe you're going
to hear that when
you make some different
and difficult decisions
over the course of your life and
you learn the lesson that what
makes you happy, it may
make others uncomfortable.
What makes you happy may
And that's OK.
Just because you're
going one way
doesn't mean it's the wrong
way people-- specifically,
our family-- have a vested
interest in us being well
taken care of and protected.
They love you.
So just know, if
you make a decision
that goes counter to what they
expect, they may not be happy.
But you gotta focus on you
and what's most important.
So back in that studio with
that red light and that camera
on me, what seemed like
a matter of minutes
was actually just a few seconds,
like a couple of seconds.
But I was able to
go through my mind
that whole story of selling
cheese, of moving to New York
City with $700 in
my bank account,
of working all those jobs, all
those things from my background
that got me to that moment
of being on the x in that
studio with those three
cameras in front of me.
And I knew right then and there
that I had to make a decision.
And that decision was
to lean into the fear
or lean into the excitement.
I couldn't articulate
it like that back then.
But I knew I had a
decision to make.
It was a willingness to bet on
me, actually double down on me
or not.
And I remember taking a
breath, looking at the camera.
And I smiled.
And I made a decision.
This is it.
And I said, what's
up, everybody?
It's a brand new episode
of "U-Pick Live."
Coming up today,
we have-- whoever
happened to be on
the show that day.
I really believe that
that moment right there,
being willing to choose me
in the face of uncertainty,
led to my being able to
work in the television
industry for over 10 years
with a lot of top networks.
Over the course of your career,
over the course of your life,
you are going to have a
lot of red light moments.
And I hope all of you
are willing to lean
into the excitement as
opposed to the fear.
Now, after you've been
willing to turn up the volume
and do the work when no one
is watching and find the edge
and lean into the excitement
as opposed to fear,
the last thing I
really want to do
is be willing to find
people who make you better.
This seems obvious, but
it doesn't happen as much
as I would like to think.
When I was an undergraduate at
Western Michigan University,
I walked on the
track and field team.
If you know anything about being
a walk-on in track and field,
that means you try
out for the team.
And if you're fortunate
enough, you made the team.
And I made the team as a long
jumper and triple jumper.
But after two years
of being on the team,
I wasn't doing so hot.
I wasn't doing well.
I remember my head coach
coming up to me one day.
And he said, Antonio,
you're not doing so well.
He said, in two years of being
on this track and field team,
you have not placed in
one major competition.
That was the agreement,
the bargain that we made,
is that you would help us
win track competitions.
But in two years of
being on this team,
you have not placed in
a major competition.
And he was right.
I think the only thing that I
placed first in those first two
years was in line at
McDonald's after our track
and field meets.
And I thought at that
moment Coach Shaw was
going to cut me from the team.
And I would lose my
opportunity to potentially earn
a scholarship, which
would have been really
helpful because my
mother at that time
was paying for my tuition
on her credit card.
But Coach Shaw didn't cut me.
Instead, he did something
else that was really powerful.
He said, Antonio, I don't
know if you know this,
but we have two all-Americans
on our track and field team.
And he pointed to
them on the track.
We have two all-Americans
on our track and field team.
Yet, in the two years that
you've been on the roster,
not once have I seen you
spend any time with them.
He was right.
One gentleman would go on
to compete in the Olympics.
Another one would
go on to compete
in the world championships.
He said, instead,
Antonio, you're
hanging out with those guys.
And he pointed over
to the high jump mat.
Now, if you know anything
about the high jump
mat in middle school or high
school or collegiate track
and field, the high jump
mat is essentially the club.
That's the people, your
teammates go, hang out, laugh,
lay back, and relax.
And that's where I spent
the majority of my time.
It's not that my teammates
on that high jump mat
were bad people and
doing bad things.
But they weren't all-Americans.
And it's true.
I didn't spend time
with those all-Americans
because they got up
earlier than I did.
They ate better than I did.
They passed on the
parties that I went to.
Why would I do that,
even though my mother
was paying for my tuition
on her credit card?
Coach Shaw walked away.
He didn't cut me.
But what Coach Shaw did
for me in that moment
was introduced me to this
concept of thieves and allies.
Thieves are those people
that don't encourage you,
that don't inspire you,
that don't challenge you,
that don't push
you, that don't hold
you accountable to
be the absolute best
version of yourself.
Thieves are those people
you spend a lot of time
having brunch with talking
about all the things
that you're going to do,
knowing that you're never
going to do them.
Thieves are those people that my
friend, the author John Gordon,
calls energy vampires.
You know those people
you spend time with them,
and after they leave,
you have less energy
than when they arrived?
These are those people
that somehow always have
drama going on in their lives.
You know anyone who has drama
always going on in their life?
You call them.
What's up?
How are you?
And they say, you're
not going to believe
what just happened to me.
It's like, why are
things always happening
to you and no one else?
You know those people?
And on the flipside, the
opportunity that we have
is a spent time with allies.
Allies are those people
that do encourage you,
that do inspire you,
that do challenge you,
that do push you, that
do hold you accountable,
that test you to be the absolute
best version of yourself.
Allies are those people
that you do spend time
with at lunch talking about all
the things you're going to do.
Then you leave lunch or brunch,
and begin working on them.
Allies are those people
that don't take energy away
from you.
They give you energy.
Allies aren't those
people that have
drama going on in their lives.
They actually have great
things going on in their lives.
The beautiful thing is
that not only can you
surround yourself with
allies, but you can also
be an ally to others.
What I'd you do right
now is just take a second
and visualize the five people,
the five people, that you spend
the most time with and ask
yourself a really simple,
yet challenging question.
And that is, do they
make you better?
Do the five people you
spend the most time with,
do they make you better?
I ask this question across
the country all the time.
And I see some people just
shake their head, like no.
You see, the thing about allies
is they provide something
that I like to call-- they
provide good friction.
And I invite all of you to find
good friction in your life.
I'm from up north in Michigan.
And we get a lot
of snow up there.
And every now and then, a car
can get stuck in the snow.
And that tire will just
be spinning in the snow.
But for us, to get
that tire moving
and get out of that
snow, what we do
is try to create friction.
So we'll put kitty
litter under that tire.
And it will propel us forward.
Or we'll put sand
under the tire.
And it will propel us
forward, or salt, you name it.
In dire circumstances
in the woods,
you can start a fire with
two sticks and some kindling.
I like to think about diamonds.
How are diamonds formed?
Under millions and millions
of years of pressure.
The soil wasn't massaging
the shoulders of diamonds.
I invite all of you
to be willing to find
good friction in your life.
Those allies are going
to hold you accountable,
but they will take you
further in your life as well.
What I find when I
go to corporations
and I go to universities is
we're in an interesting place
right now.
And that's really
scary for me because I
find that if someone receives
the slightest bit of feedback
that they disagree with,
the first response is
that person is an idiot.
My manager doesn't know what
he or she is talking about.
Or if someone doesn't
agree with the thought
that you have, on many college
campuses, people are like,
we should get him fired.
I invite you to
find good friction.
Things can come from
that, especially when it's
constructive feedback
in our lives.
Think all those times someone
has disagreed with you.
Have been willing to find that
good friction in your life?
When I was in grad school
at Columbia University,
I remember turning in
my master's thesis.
And I'd be so afraid because I
knew my master's advisor, when
he finished with it, it'd
be covered in red ink.
And I'd have so much
more work to do.
And he saw my trepidation
of submitting my thesis
to get reviewed.
And one day, he
looked at me and said,
point blank, Antonio, don't you
know you pay for the red ink?
You pay for the red ink.
Find the value in that.
Not what's wrong with it.
I think the challenging
times we're in right now
also involve this right
here, like many ways
we're doing things, I think,
for a lot of the wrong reasons.
We're doing things for likes,
for retweets, for double taps,
for views, shares, you name it.
I have a decent social
media following.
But I can tell you right
now, if I really need support
and I really need
guidance, I can
count on these two hands who
really is going to be there
for me in this life.
Those are those allies.
I invite you to
know that supporters
are greater than followers.
Over the course of
your career, supporters
are going to be
greater than followers.
And know that "we"
is greater than "me."
I invite you over
the next few days
to pay attention to the language
that you use as you communicate
with colleagues and your team.
And see if you say "I"
and "me" more than you
say "we" and "us." "I" and "me",
when it comes to communication,
creates distance.
"We" and "us," it
brings us closer.
It brings us together as a team.
And it allows us to collaborate
that much more easily.
Now, look, I really believe
that if you regularly
turn up the volume and do the
work when no one is watching,
great things can
happen in your career.
I believe that if you're
willing to find the edge
and lean into the excitement
as opposed to the fear,
amazing things will
happen in your career.
And if you find the
people who make you better
and spent time with allies
as opposed to thieves,
you will get
exceptional results.
The beautiful thing
is this is that this
is what you have right now in
your life with this internship
in your life.
You have a blank canvas, the
one that we showed you earlier.
It's your opportunity to
paint, to sculpt, to create
what you most want to create.
But it's going to require you
to have that CEO mentality,
being willing to be
proactive versus reactive,
having an agenda, identifying
what's most important.
And I cannot promise you that
everything is going to go
fantastic over the
course of your career.
It will not.
There'll be bad days,
bad weeks, bad months.
But I think about a
time I was reporting
a story on Juneau, Alaska.
If you know anything about
the weather in Juneau, Alaska,
it rains a lot.
I remember walking
around downtown Juneau,
Alaska with a big umbrella.
And I noticed that none of the
locals were using umbrellas.
I got confused.
I went up to a local.
I said, excuse me, sir.
I'm not from here.
But I noticed no one
here uses umbrellas.
Why is that?
He looked at me.
He had glasses on.
They beaded up with water.
And he said, you know, man.
It's just water.
When you're having that
bad day, that project
wasn't received the way
you thought it would,
know that it's just water.
And sometimes, we have
to let ourselves get wet.
We have to get drenched
and learn from that.
That builds up grit.
That builds up resilience.
That builds up perseverance.
That builds up
character, those things
that allow us to plow ahead
forward in the future.
The truth is this, that no one
cares-- and I hate to say this,
but no one cares more about you
and your career than you do.
Yes, your advisor
at college does.
But they can't
care more than you.
Yes, your manager cares.
But they can't
care more than you.
Yes, your parents care.
But they can't
care more than you.
Your significant other cares.
But they cannot
care more than you.
At the end of the
day, the results
you do or do not get in
your career are up to you.
Effort is between you and you.
You know what you're
willing to give
and what you are not giving.
People always give me
this notion that college,
the best years of your life.
I think that's rubbish.
That's some amazing years.
But I'm a firm
believer that the best
thing that has ever
happened to any of you
has not happened yet.
And that's how I invite you
wake up every single day when
you have this blank canvas.
Thank you so much for having me.
I really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Definitely feel free to
come say hello online.
The question was, what has
been the biggest challenge
in your career?
And I think a couple
things pop in my mind.
One the biggest
challenges was learning
how to break the cycle.
I come from a family
that didn't go
to college, that hasn't
necessarily been professionals
in their life.
So before me, there
was no track record.
There was no blueprint.
So in many ways, I had to
figure this out on my own.
But I quickly realized I
can't do this by myself.
So I've been able in the course
of my career to surround myself
with a lot of great
mentors and people
who have been there, who have
done that, to get through those
challenging times.
Because again, I
had no blueprint.
There was no one in my family
that I could go to and say,
hey, I'm experiencing
X, Y, and Z
because they hadn't
experienced that.
So as they say, it
takes a village.
Right?
And sometimes we have to
create our own village
and identify those people.
And again, people are
willing to support you.
But is there a willingness to
be humble and ask for that help?
Also, I showed you all these
networks and those cool things
that have happened in
my career, but I've
been fired from jobs as well.
Contracts haven't been renewed.
And that willingness,
that knowingness, again,
to hold-- the best thing
that has ever happened to you
hasn't happened yet.
I've had to remind myself of
that during challenging times.
The television industry
is extremely volatile.
One day you're hot,
the next you're not.
And so I had to know that
my validation in this life
can't come from
exterior motives.
On Facebook, I have one of
those blue verification badges,
like you verified.
And one day, a student asked me,
earnestly, he's like, Antonio,
how can I get verified on
Facebook or Twitter or Google+,
you name it.
And I looked at them.
And I started giving the answer.
Well, look, I work
in television.
I'm a journalist.
And I stopped.
And I said, don't you know
that you were verified
the day that you were born?
That can't no blue
badge you verify you?
No blue badge can verify you.
Really?
Oh, now I'm verified
because this organization
says I'm someone?
No.
And for a long
time in television
I sought out external
rewards and acknowledgement,
and had to realize it
started here, inside.
So I hope that
answered your question.
That's the short answer.
But I'd be willing to talk
more about that afterwards.
You have a question over here.
Just stand up and you can
just project your voice.
Absolutely, the
question is, Antonio,
over the course of
your lives, people
are going to say, hey,
what's your story?
Or tell me about yourself.
And that's a big
opportunity for you.
Unfortunately, when I see
people early on in their career,
they tend to give
the resume answer.
I'm a junior at Western
Michigan University.
I'm studying in marketing.
I'm originally from Jackson.
And there's this long, boring,
chronological story that
makes me want to fall asleep.
And it's not because
they're bad people.
It's just that no one has
told them anything otherwise.
Now, your goal when someone
says, what's your story,
tell me about yourself--
whether it's on a plane,
in line at Starbucks, or in a
job interview-- is hopefully
to get this response from
that person after you answer.
And that is this.
Tell me more about that.
Your goal is to get someone to
say, tell me more about that,
to draw them in.
So what I invite all of
you to do is take some time
and identify three
things in your life
that really make you unique,
that not many people know
about you, those
things that would never
show up on a resume.
Many times, those
things will never
show up in a Google search.
I mean, there are many students
that work full-time while going
to school full-time.
They don't think
it's no big deal.
They're just doing
what they gotta
do to pay for their education.
But I can tell you right now,
if you were in a job interview,
and someone says, tell
me about yourself,
and you started off with well,
I'm a student at Kennesaw State
University and I work full-time
to pay for my education,
right then and there, that
person who is interviewing you
is going to know something
special about you.
This person is really willing to
put in the work and the effort.
Or if you happen to be
an international student
and you mention that I'm
an international student.
I'm originally from
XYZ country, which
is not a country, by the way.
I'm just saying XYZ
just for an example.
I'm from XYZ country.
I came here to
pursue my education.
And you tell a little bit of
that story, the arc of how
you got here, that's a lot.
You know how hard it
is to uproot yourself
from another country and
then move to another country
and then maybe learn something
and study something that's
not your first language?
That draws people in.
That means you're
willing to find the edge
and get uncomfortable.
Some people with different
organizations do mission trips.
And they go and they
volunteer their time.
And they teach English,
or they do other things.
Find those things that would
never show up on a resume.
Right?
I tell people, I
used to sell cheese.
Tell me more about
that, Antonio.
But those things, again,
that would never show up,
that would draw them in.
And what that does is it
creates a human connection, not
a business transaction.
Your goal is to create
a human connection.
The best job interviews are
the ones where you rarely
talk about the resume.
You know you've got somebody
during a job interview when
they're like this
in the beginning.
Then they just put it down.
You start having a
human conversation.
So those things that
people would never
find on your resume.
And sometimes it's really
hard to identify those things
on your own.
So have a conversation
with a friend or just
to interview like a journalist
to get some of those
to come out.
I hope that was helpful.
Right, so the question
is, if you're not
a person who
energizes others, what
can you do to help that
person to become that?
So listen, I want
to make sure we're
talking about the same thing.
Are we talking about being
a negative energy vampire?
Or you're just more,
let's say, introverted
in communicating with others
in certain capacities?
It isn't natural for you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANTONIO NEVES: OK.
Look, those energy
vampires, that's
a whole other
conversation that I really
can't answer on this stage.
The biggest thing is awareness.
Sometimes, when you
make people aware
that they can be a
negative influence
on a room or a gathering, they
may get a little bit defensive.
So you have to hope that they
are open to actually hearing
that feedback.
If it's unsolicited, just know
they may not receive it well.
If you're not naturally
an extroverted person
and you can be a
little bit quiet,
you're a little bit reserved,
I'll just give example.
When you go to a
networking event,
just don't make
it a numbers game.
Some people go to networking
events or meetings
or gatherings or
company gatherings,
and they try to meet everyone.
And that's absolutely
exhausting.
What I'd say is, it's
OK to be who you are.
Don't shy away from that
and all of a sudden present
yourself as someone you're
not, some big personality.
But in that event you attend,
find one or two people
to connect with and choose
quality over quantity, where
you actually can be yourself.
Nothing is more exhausting
than not being you
and not being yourself.
Don't get me wrong.
You're going to find
situations in job interviews
where you do need to
have that good posture,
that forward energy.
You're going to have
to project your voice.
To give talks on
stage, you may have
to-- there are things
you can do with that.
But I think in human
interactions, just be yourself.
But don't try to
connect with everybody.
Instead of trying to talk
to five people and once
and be that big storyteller,
if that's not you,
connect one-on-one.
Know where you shine.
And know where you don't shine.
Right?
Yeah.
The question is, how
do you figure out
where you want to go
eventually if you don't
know where you want to go?
Right?
It's a good question.
It's a conundrum, one that
I've experienced before.
My answer to that is
just your willingness
to be curious and not
put pressure on yourself
to actually know.
You may have an
overarching interest.
Say it's in technology.
Right?
So it may not make
a lot of sense
for you to pursue working
in the hotel industry.
Right?
Well, that actually could
be technology as well.
But I have a chapter in my book.
And it's titled, "Your First
Job Won't Be Your Last Job."
So I invite you not to
put a lot of pressure
on yourself to
get that first job
right because knowing
that in a couple years,
you're going to
go somewhere else.
But your willingness to get
curious and try new things out,
again, knowing that
this is not going
be my final position or
my final decision ever.
But what can I learn
from this situation?
So a lot of times,
it's trial and error.
Just get curious, but don't
put pressure on yourself
to make the right decision.
And I think in due
time, as you accumulate
data, like life data, you're
going to learn what you like
and what you don't like.
Don't forget that
is just as viable
to know what you don't want to
do as it is to know what you do
want to do.
So for me, when I spent
a year doing something.
I don't want to do that.
Selling cheese?
That was like, yes, I know
I don't want to sell cheese.
That's a victory.
Now, some people may frame it
another way-- I wasted a year.
I didn't waste a year.
I learned something
I did not want to do.
So be willing to experiment
with things that you find out
you don't like.
And that's OK.
It's a journey.
It's a big canvas.
So there may be a small
corner of cheese in your life.
But there's more room to paint.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANTONIO NEVES: Well, hey,
thank you so much everyone.
I appreciate you.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]